important lesson for young people in our
time don't put off whatever it is you're
meant to do until the situation is
optimal don't fail to pursue what it is
you think you're meant to pursue in your
life until you have total Tranquility
that you have the house or the apartment
you would like until you have the
relationship you would like don't put it
off until then or until the world is
peaceful which will never happen never
has happened never will happen don't put
it off till then because if you put it
off till then it means you'll put it off
forever so do whatever you're meant to
be doing now start now if you haven't
started already and if you start it
already don't go any slower this is part
of the cost of our times part of the
cost of our times is the enormous
expense of energy on idiotic things that
you can do nothing about I think we
should say to more people don't Howl at
the Moon don't shake your fists at the
skies get on with what you're meant to
be doing